this is a Wendover productions video
made possible by hover get 10% off your
custom domain with hover with the code
Wendover I check out the Arctic will be
perhaps the single most influential
region on earth in the coming century
and yet almost no one even lives there
eight nations have territory above the
Arctic Circle Denmark through their
constituent country Greenland Iceland
Norway Sweden Finland Russia the United
States and Canada and they are all in
close quarters this circle represents
the distance a plane can fly in three
hours
most of these countries can reach each
other faster than they can watch Titanic
Anchorage Alaska is in fact closer to
tromsø Norway than it is to New York
because of this short cut over the pole
alert Canada is so close to tromsø
Norway that it can be flown by a
turboprop plane the only issue is
there's about to be some serious money
in the high north the Arctic ice is
melting there's no question about that
some may debate the cause of the melt
but one cannot debate that there's
simply less ice up north than there was
50 years ago this melt has profound
consequences whole countries like Tuvalu
and the Maldives could be largely
underwater by the end of the century
because of the rising sea levels from
melting ice
but the melt has a different more
obvious effect where there was once ice
there's now liquid
navigable water one of the greatest
quest for early explorers was to find a
Northwest Passage a navigable sea route
connecting the Atlantic and the Pacific
Oceans through the Canadian archipelago
it was long thought to be a myth until
in 1906 Roald Amundsen and his six crew
members arrived at Herschel Island
Canada having successfully completed a
three-year journey from Norway via the
new Northwest Passage the significance
of the Northwest Passage is that until
1914 when the Panama Canal opened
traffic from the Atlantic could only
reach the Pacific by sailing around Cape
Horn the southern tip of South America
this meant that a sea route between
London and San Francisco 5,000 miles
apart as the crow flies took 14,000
miles this was not efficient it was a
significant hamper to
development American West Coast the
Northwest Passage would have
revolutionized maritime trade if it
wasn't covered in ice Roald Amundsen
ship the yoha was small enough that
could snake through and slide over ice
some of the waterways Amundsen took
where as few as 3 feet deep far too
shallow for the increasingly large
commercial ships of the time more than a
hundred years later in September of 2013
however for the very first time a
commercial bulk carrier the MS Nordic
Orion transited an almost ice-free
Northwest Passage on its journey from
Vancouver Canada to pori Finland and
this was far from a publicity stunt this
ship saved $80,000 in fuel costs and was
able to take 25% more cargo than if it
had gone through the Panama Canal even
thousand passenger cruise ships are now
making the journey ironically global
warming is actually opening a route
that's better for the environment China
is a country with a vested interest in
the navigability of the Northwest
Passage as an economy largely based on
manufacturing for the Western world
their maritime accessibility has an
enormous effect on their national
well-being a reduction in time and cost
of shipping to the American East Coast
would renew their competitiveness in the
manufacturing industry against emerging
rivals such as Vietnam and Bangladesh as
China industrialized largely thanks to
its manufacturing industry the standard
of living in the country increased which
correspondingly increased labor costs
China's maritime safety administration
recognizing the imminent explosion in
usage recently published a 356 page
guide to navigating the Northwest
Passage and the country has announced
plans to send more and more commercial
shipping traffic through the passage in
coming summers the introduction of
maritime traffic to the Northwest
Passage could present a significant
opportunity for Canada the northern
territories of Canada through which the
Northwest Passage runs are historically
underdeveloped less than a hundred and
twenty thousand people live in the Yukon
the Northwest Territories and Nunavut
that's less than the population of
saguenay a town small enough that
there's a good chance you haven't
and heard of it living in an area larger
than the entire country of India it's
not all that surprising considering just
how inhospitable the area is but other
places at similar latitudes such as
Anchorage Longyearbyen and Murmansk have
managed to overcome the conditions
thanks to the money that can be made in
the far north if a large chunk of the
world's maritime traffic heads to the
Canadian north industry will develop to
support these ships except there's a
problem despite the general friendliness
of most of the Arctic countries there
are geopolitical issues in the high
north even more surprisingly one of them
is between the u.s. and Canada when
there's a navigation choke point
restricting certain countries from
accessing an ocean its convention to
declare that waterway an international
waterway for example the Danish Straits
fully surrounded by Denmark are an
international waterway in order to give
the Baltic and Scandinavian countries
ocean access the Turkish straits fully
surrounded by Turkey are international
waterways to give the Black Sea
country's ocean access and the Danube
River is an international waterway to
give land lock austria-hungary moldova
serbia and slovakia ocean access when a
waterway is declared an international
waterway no country can restrict access
or charge dues to passing boats except
during a time of war canada considers
the waterways comprising the northwest
passage in their archipelago as their
own waters in the past nobody challenged
this since there was no reason anyone
would cut through these frozen waters
with its promise to cut shipping routes
by thousands of miles the Northwest
Passage will almost certainly become an
important shipping route so that's why
countries like the US firmly believe
that the Northwest Passage should be an
already is an international waterway one
of the tensest moments in history
between the US and Canada was when in
1985 a US Coast Guard icebreaker
traveled through the Northwest Passage
without prior permission from Canada in
Canada's mind this was a military
invasion of their sovereign territory
debated Lee an act of war Canada argues
that the Northwest Passage is not an
international waterway because it has
failed to meet an important criteria
usefulness of course the Northwest
Passage is useful on paper
if shortens the route between the oceans
but Canada has pointed out that in
previous cases determining whether a
waterway is international what proves a
routes usefulness is if a significant
number of shifts have already
successfully transited it in the
northwest passages case the number of
successful commercial journeys is in the
double digits
there's also merit to Canada's argument
that the passage should be their
sovereign waters currently Canada has
almost no search and rescue capabilities
in their archipelago since there's
almost no traffic yet there's no reason
to spend the money to put ships and
aircraft up there most previous journeys
have been highly coordinated and often
escorted by the Canadian Coast Guard if
a ship just went through with no prior
coordination nowadays and sank however
it would be almost no chance of rescue
for the victims if in a few summers
hundreds of ships transit passage Canada
would have an obligation to put
resources in the northern provinces with
the safety of both the country and
sailors and that takes money if treated
as an internal waterway Canada could
charge passage fees just as there are
for the Panama or Suez Canal the other
major shipping shortcuts of the world
these could fund the infrastructure
needed to safely regulate and police the
route but on the other hand should one
country have the capability to choose
who can get from the Atlantic to the
Pacific faster letting for example
Vietnamese ships through the route but
banning Chinese ships would make the
Chinese goods uncompetitive for the
Western European and Eastern American
market Canada would have the capability
to choose which economies can succeed
and which will fail there's a reason the
issues so contentious scientists
disagree on the exact state but there's
a general consensus that by the year
2050 there will be a summer when there
is no ice in the Arctic this will have
enormous and irreversible consequences
but it could further revolutionize how
we get our goods an ice-free Arctic will
open up the greatest shipping shortcut
in the world the Arctic Ocean ships
traveling between Japan and Western
Europe for example instead of heading
south across the Indian Ocean through
the Suez Canal and across the
Mediterranean Sea we'll be able to head
north through the Bering Strait directly
across the Arctic Ocean and down between
Greenland and
Norway to Europe that's a 7,000 mile
route compared to the 13,000 mile route
of today that has the potential to slash
shipping prices in half that means
cheaper products across the entire world
but at what cost every degree of climate
warming in the US alone is expected to
cause 144 billion dollars per year of
economic loss if the US climate warms by
12 degrees which the EPA says is
possible by 2100 the US can expect to
lose more than 1.7 trillion dollars per
year that's more than a full percent of
its GDP on top of that by 2050 climate
change is expected to cause more than
250,000 guests per year surely that
can't be worth it for some cheaper goods
this video was made possible by hover I
recently bought two new domains with
hover the website for my new podcast
show makers FM and an extra domain for
my Wendover production site Wendover dot
productions with show makers FM I
connected it to a hosting provider in
seconds and with Wendover dot
productions I set it to redirect to my
site in seconds it was incredibly easy I
also love how the price they show you is
the price you pay
there aren't page after page of add-ons
like with some other sites now having a
professional web presence is important
and it all starts with the domain what
can really set you apart is a unique
domain extension that's the bit at the
end like com FM or even dot pizza and
hover has over 400 of them once you buy
a domain through hover you can set up an
email account using that domain which
will truly help you stand out however
you want to use hover you can get 10%
off your first order and help out
Wendover productions by going to hover
com slash Wendover and using the code
Wendover at checkout get your unique
domain and email to help you stand out
with hover please also be sure to check
out my new podcast with Brian from real
engineering called show makers episode 1
with Hank green and 2 with Destin
Sandlin from smarter every day are
already out links are in the description
you can also support Wendover
productions on patreon here follow me on
Twitter at Wendover Pro watch my last
video here
check out my fan moderated subreddit
here and lastly subscribe to this
channel by clicking here
thanks again for watching and I'll see
you in two weeks for another Wendover
productions video